What's up
its time for me to play a video game everybody
this one is called mother simulator
look what a goofy ...
ahh there is a poop at the wall.
on the ceiling?
how is that even possible ?
select a challenge
meet the baby
ok
* crowd cheers*
this is how the game begins
it looks like I'm about to take a snack on the baby
I don't look like a much of a mother
alright its baby time
Now i have a timer so I best hurry
oh god thats awkward
what do I do with this ?
oh he needs a diaper
OK
uhh put it down
oh my god.
thats fine
its still alive
it will be fine
uhh now I just gotta
grab the thing and drop
I did it!!!
*pewds laugh*
im a geni...
no wait it lost it.
right grab it
AAND
drop it.
no
grab it
AAANDDD
and drop it
SUCK the thing
you stupid baby
It worked before
*cries*
Gravity is a
alright
grab the baby
oh my god whats wrong with you
sit down...
*pewds laugh*
oh my god.
something is wrong with my child
something is terribly wrong
oh I know whats wrong
you need a little....
pacifi-
Wha- I gave it to him!
stupid game
ok listen up kid
we're gonna do this one way and one way only
alright sit down
I said sit down
thats right now succ it
come on baby
oh
I can't- there we go
no
what did-
the controls are so delayed like oh my god
what a stupid face
this is not my child
IT keep-
EAT THE THING
PUT IT IN!!!
PUT IT IN!!!!
PUT IT IN YOUR MOUTH
WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU
you're going in the sink have a time out
thats right you're going in the sink
you need to cool off
what am I doing wrong here
thats German
alright are you gonna behave?
are you gonna behave now
ok what if I just get the pacifier
and I just give that to the baby
WHAT IS YOUR FRIKEN PROBLEM??
wait i gotta maybe hold it
here take it
take it
don't look at me like that Timmy
Timmy
what am I supposed to do with you?
alright how bout this how bout this
I SWEAR TO GOD
alright how do I kill a baby
*sad music*
*poor child*
do I need to dip it in something so he'll suck it like maybe honey or something
right? maybe thats it
stop spitting it out
maybe I just need to keep giving it to him
stop
I need instructions
I gotta wash it
I gotta wash the -I gotta wash it
thats all I had to do
how do I get it in there
I can't reach it
its dirty its dirty thats why
oh my god
so how do I get it in there
there we go
there we go I'm doin- I'm doin- I'm doing it!
now here you go baby
in you go
TAKE IT
I don't have time for your games baby
WOOOOOO
yeah baby
I just realize is my hat green?
*laughs*
cool
now gift from the baby is the next goal
it seems your robot kid may pee
our waterproof ultra absorbent fireproof nappy
now taste of strawberries
do it so he can feel dryness and comfort
easy
im a great mother
I'm- I'm probably the best mother
-of all time, alright lil Timmy
uh alright so let me ju- oh sorry
well yeah ok so
whats step two
step two, whats step one
step two
ok
no
step two
put them in the bin
you get a bonus point if i throw them from a range ok
hah
can you be quiet? I'm trying to do the game here
oh sorry oops
*pewds laugh*
ok uh lets just drop it here
no I'm missing it every time
how do I throw?
it doesn't-
it doesn't throw it!
this game sucks
alright grab the diaper
throw it in the thing
ok and then
ba- oh we gotta get the baby here come on Timmy
I aint got time
I aint got time Timmy
oh I gotta spray you
how do I spray you
but- Timmy! sit!
Timmy!!
go- thank you
alright alright alright alright
ok Timmy
Timmy there we go
this is how its done
no put them on
did it
I- I told you
I told you I'm a great mother
people don't recognize
next stop dinner
ok no problem
I make excellent dinner
all the time
ask anybody
just watch me
alright pacifier you need pacifier ok
alright so its dirty
so we need to clean it of course
clean clean clean clean clean clean cleannn
and we're gonna place it there
perf- oh great its dirty now
thats fine
alright we're gonna clean
clean clean clean clean clean
we're gonna put it down here
we're gonna put it down there
look at dat
alright
just gonna-
just gonna grab this
there we go
alright eh we *laughs*dropped the thing
thats fine just gonna put that down there
and we're gonna clean it again
not a problem we got plenty of time here
ok put that down there
and there we're gonna heat some water
we're gonna grab Timmy
and Timmy's gonna get some-
OH MY GOD TIMMY NOOO
Timmy's a demon
*sad piano*
jeez
Timmy please come back to us
alright its fine ignore the demon baby
we still have to make water
there you go thank you Timmy for helping out
I really really appreciate
DAMN IT ITS DIRTY AGAIN TIMMY
you suck
god I hate this child
come here
there you go sit down
I'm trying to be a good mother
alright- DAMN IT!
alright just fill it again just fill it again
just fill it again
we got plenty of time Felix
GOD DAMN IT
why does it keep flying everywhere
screw it
screw it on
YES!
you see that Timmy?!
you see that?!
you see what I'm talking about
thats what I'm talking ab-
*disappointed in life*
BE QUIET GAME
oh my god Timmy
Timmy stop merging with things
MY GOD
sit down Timmy
alright we gonna grab this
Timmy it's feeding time
Timmy's too far away
Alright put him here-
ARE YOU KIDDING ME
this game was rigged against you
I swear I am a great mother
alright let's try this again
Water
See? this system is rigged against our dads
So it's easy when you know how to do it
Obviously.
So what's step... three
WHAT DA HECK
IS YOUR PROBLEM?!
you made it dirty
I swear this kid has an attitude problem
I don't know where he gets it from
Timmy!
eat the friking bottle
EAT IT
EAT THE BOTTLE!!!
OH RIGHT IT'S EMPTY
Ahh okay
Alright
I don't care
That's right I forgot of course its empty or it's empty
MY BAD TIMMY
MY BAD
Alright so I just-
GOD
DAMN IT
Alright (inaudible)
We'll take it easy
We'll take it in ea-
We'll take it in easy
We'll take it in easy got plenty of time
got plenty of time
Don't worry Timmy I got you daddy's got you
Alright
Daddy's got you Timmy
Daddy's loves you very mu-
AGGAHHHHH
We got a minute we still got a minute
Just put dat down
Nice and easy
Nice and ez
Clean Clean Clean
Click click click
grab
no?
grab it
Timmy
Timmy?
You look a lil down here you go
oh ma god it got dirty cuz he's on the floor
Go there
Timmy Im no-
TIMMY IM NOT PLAYING GAMES
TIMMY THIS IS NOT A GAME!!
oh I gotta mix the baby powder!
Timmy i'm so sorry I didn't know about the baby powder
Who knew?
Who knew kids can't just-
ehh
Who knew kids can't-
ARE YOU KIDDING MEEE?!
It will go in
I swear to god Timmy
I will murder you
20 SECONDS!!!
We're doing this for Timmy
godammit
Alright it's in
It's good enough
Gimme dat
Here we go
Here we go where are you?
Where are you?
Where is he? there you go
Would've thought its so hard
Shoutout to all the moms out there
I had no idea
Just fill it out with water
And now we put it down
And we add the thing
Alright I assume it's in
I assume it's in
No visual confirmation but thats good enough
Here you go you spoiled lil piece of garbage
DON'T SPIT IT OUT
I WILL KIL-  ok cool
What now? he wants the stupid pacifier
You're such a stupid lil child Timmy
Here you go you dumbass
TOOTTOTOTOOOOOT
*claps*
hurray
I have to look after myself?
Aw its so hard enough being a baby
I mean having a baby
I didn't think it was possible to hate babies
More than I was already doing myself
Alright so its dirty
so we gonna wash it
That's actually not a problem
But then apparently im hungry as well
Alright here you go sucker
Suck on that
Biiiiit
Okay so let's have some pie
Let's have some pie
Let's have some croissants
Some sweets
Okay guys
This is epic
And while we have spare time
We can wash up our stuff
Oh my god im having the time of my life
Would've thought being a father
Was this- I mean mother
This- being this rewarding
I feel like a kid again
What can I say
Look we're so ahead
Being a mother is eeeasy
It's eeeasy
It's all-
It's always been easy
Anyone complaining?
It's so hard to be a mother?
You don't kno- you haven't
seen you haven't played this game as
good as I have
clearly don't hate the
player what do you want all right
I gotchu fam
I gotchu
now what we need
here luckily I've already prepared for
this
I know that little rascal would get
hungry
that's fine
*grumbling noise*
okay fill it up
put it down
grab this
and don't make it fall
it gets good enough
all right we got to
eat real fast bread
bread and then put
this on and put that on
Timmy
Timmy you're gonna love this
you're gonna love it
it's empty
DON'T THROW IT
WE DON'T
THROW
THINGS IN
THIS HOUSE
Shoot I'm dying
I'm dying uhh berries
*crunch*
*cronch*
uh we just need the berries
guyyy got 30
that's fine that's fine
we have plenty of time boys
we got pleeenty of time
don't make it fall over
there we go it's in
it's in
Timmy you best eat this
or I'll kill you
what are you doing on the ground?
idiot go back here
here
that's right suck it up
suck all of it
that's right
You lil
all right where is his pacifier
where is it then
where is it AHH disgusting
where is his pacifier
I'm dying
I'm dying any these sausages
where is it stupid pacifier there we go
we're going for it boys
we're boy oh boy in for it boy suck it
suck it sit down now what now what
diaper no problem there you go damnit I
gotta do all that again are you kidding
me daddy don't love you okay I'm only
taking care of you because your mother
left you and I'm starting to understand
why you're useless you trash you're
nothing but a poopoo suck it
oh shoot I need to eat I'm sorry I
didn't mean to throw you I had no choice
oh my god no no okay all right we're
just gonna have to go with it oh my god
what is happening I don't oh my god
Oh God all right that's it that's it I'm
officially done being a mother put it on
oh my god I'm eat eat I get it yes Josh
slay Queen patty pie that's right I'm a
mother
how many nappies oh it's a robot kid
that's right that's right YouTube
that's right YouTube do monetization
it's a robot kid it's not a real kid
how many Nappers okay all right this
seems stupid everything else has been
anyway
all right it's time how do I throw them
all right throw them how do I throw them
I just throw you then oh come on
seriously I don't understand how you're
supposed to throw them I can only do the
mic drop
you let your Lily oh I got it
good right click what
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah feeling like I'm
Jordan 3-point yeah I'm scoring
oh yeah come on I gotta hit some max oh
oh oh my god I'm the best mom in the
world baby you see that timmy little
shit factoring oh I'll get dunked on bit
join faze clan next look at it look at
it look at it son look at your dad food
poisoning
Oh No
where's the freaking toilet here it is
it must be here Alexa this is a perfect
how do I put down the child normally
okay and then a new pair of diapers
quite easily
Sam good assist I'm damn good at since I
was born to do
this is really hard
look at this sucky sucky yeah yeah yeah
what you got what you got Timmy
you throw it in your own stupid face you
dumb ball diaper BAM
come here Timmy daddy's coming
yeah yeah
ice age are you kidding me Timmy it's
the I oh my god I'm sliding are you
kidding me
Timmy I ca I say why won't you just die
how am i how do I have water for my pad
this game makes no sense am i right guys
god damn it put it in its ice age I have
food poisoning and I have the worst
child of all time what the heck is going
on all right what does Timmy one now
diapers are no problem to me
watch this Timmy whatever whatever it
doesn't matter you're irrelevant Timmy I
know I'm hungry game but Timmy needs a
diaper grab it come on Chabad this is
the play of the century crush on Barry
yeah yeah what next
Brad there's only one thing I can do hey
Timmy hey Timmy it's not so funny now is
it I was being a baby now smash like on
this video Timmy
or else thank you guys for watching this
video leave a like if you think I can be
a great mother and smash like if you
think I want I will be sure to read all
your comments and appreciated feedback
this has been mother simulator I'll see
you guys tomorrow with another video
sash and subscribe